our meet Dylan has followed all of this
closely from the inside she's the
founder of the Dylan Law Group hermit
thanks so much for coming on tonight so
let's start
um with a specific question Jermaine to
the race in which Donald Trump is
engaged he's the front owner by 30
points in you have seen cases
politicized cases as with Roger Stone in
which the person charged is gagged by
the judge and not allowed to speak about
the charges this is increasingly common
in violation of the First Amendment
obviously but it happens
if this happens to Donald Trump he will
lose his Free Speech rights as a
candidate in a presidential race and I'm
just wondering if you think that could
potentially happen
well it very much could happen in fact
we've seen it talked about on television
already and in fact the the president
has been subject to similar former
president subject to similar allegations
in other litigation that he's involved
and also Way Beyond the statute of
limitations the story is that because he
says mean things about people sometimes
on his Free Speech platforms that he
should not be allowed to speak about a
fundamental issue of due process that
governs the future of our country and
how we look at Justice and how we look
at the politicism politicization of this
political process and so that would be a
gross miscarriage of Justice if it
occurs and I would not be surprised to
see this politicized prosecutor make
that request of this judge
I I honestly think it's impossible to
imagine greater election interference a
greater or more aggressive attack on our
democracy than gagging a presidential
candidate in a presidential year I mean
Vladimir Putin has never dreamed of any
attack on the United States more
damaging than that
would anyone be able to stop it
well certainly the lawyers in this case
will argue against that and it may be
the kind of issue that they seek an
immediate Appeal on if they lose but at
the end of the day if a court sets those
rules then you know litigan has to abide
by them or be in contempt of court and
you know that itself would be a very
dangerous course to pursue and so yes no
matter which way you cut it this entire
case from its Inception to its
continuation to its now being brought to
fruition uh what we hear from the New
York Times not from anything that the
DA's office has told the defense team is
that there are 30 plus charges we don't
know what they are the New York Times
knows what they are and so this is not
the way that Justice is meant to go in
the United States and what I'm afraid of
Tucker is that this isn't just going to
be about Donald Trump it's going to
undermine all citizens confidence in the
rule of law in this country and that is
really tragic
yeah it is and it has far-reaching and
Lasting generational consequences that I
don't think anyone's thought through
Army Dylan I appreciate your wise and
measure perspective as always thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight